PROFESSOR: We're
going to be talking
about adiabatic approximation.
It's an interesting
approximation
that we can do when
some physical parameters
of your system change slowly.
And sometimes, things
don't change slowly.
For example, if you
have a uniform--
a non-constant magnetic field.
OK, that's spatial
variation, no time variation.
But suppose you send
the particle in.
The particle sees a
changing magnetic field,
because it's going from one
region of low magnetic fields,
say, to a region of
high magnetic field.
So if the particle is
going at slow velocity,
it's seeing a slowly-changing
magnetic field,
even though the magnetic
field itself is not changing.
So there are several
circumstances
in which slow variations
can be important.
There can be cases where
the magnetic field is slowly
changing in time.
You have a spin, and
the magnetic field
in which the spin is
located is slowly changing,
and then you want to
know what happens.
So when a physical
quantity in your system,
in your Hamiltonian,
changes slowly,
you would expect that
your dynamical variables,
to some degree, will
change slowly as well.
And they will adjust
themselves in a slow manner
to these changes.
And that's all true.
And we kind of expect it.
But there are some
things that actually
change very slowly, not just
slowly, but very slowly.
And those are things
that are adiabatic.
Adiabatic changes correspond
to things that change,
due to some reason, even more
slowly, perhaps, than you
would have anticipated.
And that's the kind
of surprising thing
that we need to understand.
So we will begin with an
example in classical mechanics
to illustrate this point.
And so our subject is
adiabatic approximation.
And we go, then, to
classical mechanics
to get a hint of
what can happen.
And a typical example
could be you're here,
and you have a pendulum.
And the pendulum
is going this way.
But you raise up
and down your hand--
lift up and down your hand, so
that the length of the pendulum
varies.
And therefore, the frequency
of oscillation varies.
So this is a very
simple system, in which
you have a Hamiltonian
that depends on x and p,
and a frequency that
depends on time.
You've prescribed it.
It's some frequency
that depends on time.
So here it is. p squared over
2m plus 1/2 m omega squared of t
x squared.
OK, so omega is
changing in time.
And x and p--
this is classical motion, so
it's all classical physics.
This is going to be
classical motion.
Therefore, x and p are going
to be functions of time.
Well, let's see
how things change.
So let's calculate what would be
the change of the Hamiltonian,
or the total energy
as a function of time.
Now this is a
time-dependent Hamiltonian.
There's no such obvious thing
as conservation of energy.
You're doing some work here
that is changing omega.
So the amount of energy that
this system has will change.
So time-dependent
Hamiltonian like
that, the energy of the
system changes here.
So let's calculate
the change in time.
So x and p change in time.
And therefore, this changes
in time, x changes in time,
omega changes in time, and
the energy changes in time.
So let's calculate how this
energy changes in time.
So what should we do?
We should do dH dx
times the rate of change
of x because H depends on x.
dH dp times the
change in time of p.
We use dots for
time derivatives.
And then finally, we also
have to differentiate
H, with respect to time
to take into account
the variation of omega,
which is a parameter here.
So all these things
must be done.
And let's assume these
are functions of time
because the system is
doing physical motion.
So we're trying
to investigate how
the energy changes if the
system is doing physical motion.
And here is the 0-th order
result. If somebody would say,
OK, the frequency is
going to change slow,
then you could say,
OK, adiabatic result
is that the energy is
going to change slowly.
True, but not too interesting.
We're going to do better than
that, much better than that.
So let's think a little more.
If the motion is satisfying
the equations of motion--
this is physical motion
we're trying to understand,
how the energy changes
as this particle,
its doing its motion--
we can use equations of
motion of the system.
These are the Hamiltonian
equations of motion that
say dH dp is equal to x dot.
And dH dx is equal
to minus p dot.
These are the
Hamilton's equations
of motion of
classical mechanics.
It is a property of
your education at MIT
that you probably are
less familiar with those
than the quantum equivalent.
So let me remind you of
the quantum equivalent.
If you have iH
bar d dt of x, you
remember that by Ehrenfest, this
is xH commutator expectation
value.
That's Ehrenfest theorem.
And here, you also
remember that x
can be thought as iH bar d
dp, such in the same way as p
can be thought as
H bar over i d dx.
So this commutator,
the way we compute it,
is as iH bar d dp of
H expectation value.
And that's-- cancel the iH's.
And here, you've got x
dot is dH dp, the quantum
version of that.
You have also seen
that iH bar d dt of p
is equal to expectation
value of p with H.
And that would be H
bar over i dH dx using
that p as that derivative.
And that, canceling
the H bars and noticing
you have an i and
a 1 over i here,
gives you this equation
with a minus sign.
So these are
Hamilton's equations
from classical mechanics that,
in case you have not seen them,
you know they're
quantum analogs.
And you probably believe
that that is the case.
Now, that has an important
consequence on all of this,
that the first two terms
in this expression cancel,
because dH dx gives
you a minus p dot.
So you get minus p dot x dot.
And from here, you get p dot x
dot, so the two terms cancel.
And we get that the
dH dt is just dH dt.
It's kind of nice because if
there was no explicit time
dependence in the Hamiltonian,
the energy should be conserved.
And therefore, it's nice
that all that is left
is just dH dt, which we can
evaluate from the formula
up there.
We just have to
differentiate omega.
So this gives you m omega
omega dot x squared.
It's a result that
is of interest.
So, so far so good.
The energy will change.
And if omega changes slowly,
the energy will change slowly.
Nothing too dramatic.
We need to do better.
So let's think more
precisely, what
do we mean by adiabatic change?
So basically, it means that
the time scale for change
is much bigger than the time
scale for an oscillation
of your system.
So this omega is going
to change in time.
But now you can ask-- given an
omega there is a period, maybe
a second.
So probably,
adiabatic change will
hold if the change in omega
is small over a second--
if the change in omega
maybe happens over a year,
with omega being
about one second.
So this is a little like we
had in the WKB approximation.
I'll make the point here.
So here is, for example, a
typical graph that one draws.
Here is omega of t.
And that's a constant,
then it changes a bit.
And it stabilizes after a
while in some time, tau,
for a finite change
in omega of t
from some initial value
to some later value.
In this case, the
timescale from change, tau,
should be much
bigger than the time
period of isolation,
which is 2 pi over omega
of t, which is the period.
But let's be a
little more precise,
like the way we did
for the WKB case.
What did we have
in the WKB case?
We said that the change
in the Broglie wavelength
over the Broglie
wavelength was much smaller
than to the Broglie wavelength.
Or the change in energy
over the Broglie wavelength
was much smaller than
the energy of the system.
So here, we can say the
change in omega of t
over a period is much
smaller than omega of t.
So how do we say that?
Here is the rate
of change of omega.
This is, roughly, the change
in omega over a period.
So rate of change in
omega-- this is the period,
so that's, roughly, the change
in omega over a period--
must be much smaller
than omega itself.
So this is 2 pi
over omega squared.
d omega dt is much
smaller than 1.
And we can write it
in two different ways.
This says, actually, that
omega dot over omega squared
is much less than 1.
That's one way of writing it.
Forget the 2 pi.
And the other way is
by saying that this
is d dt of 2 pi over
omega much less than 1.
That's correct, because when
you differentiate 1 over omega,
you get d omega dt times
1 over omega squared.
And therefore, this is dT
period dt is much less than 1,
which might remind you
of the WKB's d lambda dx
was much less than 1.
This was WKB, very,
very analogous.